[Music]
can a war be just if lots of civilians
die Oxford University's Nigro biger
writes about this in the magazine this
week in war civilian suffering can be
moral and legal he says Nigel joins me
now Niger biger welcome to SP TV now if
anyone watching the war unfold in Gaza I
think they would be horrified by the
scale of the civilian destruction um but
you write in the magazine this week that
it horrific scale doesn't tell us
anything about its morality or it
legality tell us about that no you're
quite right the the scale of human
suffering in Gaza is is um awful um but
the fact is that that um War involves a
lot of tragic human suffering um the
laws of War uh do not prohibit the
killing of lots of civilians
uh the laws of war prohibit the
intentional killing of civilians and the
disproportionate killing that's to say
killing that is not necessary to achieve
um a an important military
objective um um and and the reason the
laws of war are permissive in that way
is because you can't fight a war
successfully without risking civilian
casualties often and certainly during
the second world war the Allies um uh
caused Grievous harm to civilians not
because they wanted it not because they
intended it uh but because there was no
other way of fighting the Nazis
effectively so you're saying if you
think that war needs to happen then
civilians sometimes need to die I I'm
I'm afraid so not not in every case but
but but usually that that that is the
case um I mean if you're a pacifist then
of course no casualties military or or
non-military are are acceptable morally
if you're not a pacifist um then uh
you're going to have to accept there
will be a lot of tragic deaths and the
World War II example was really
interesting I didn't realize until
reading your piece just how much
civilian lives were lost can you tell us
about that yeah so so most people in in
the west certainly in the English
speaking West think that the war to um
defeat genocidal Nazism in Europe was
more the Justified but a conservative
estimate has it that Allied um that's to
say British and American bombers killed
uh around 350,000 German
civilians uh now that controversial of
course because the British particularly
under bomma Harris um um may have um
deliberately intended to to kill German
civilians which was was
immoral um but uh they didn't intend to
kill 70,000 French civilians which is
what uh happened in France um during the
second world war and during The crucial
uh Normandy campaign the invasion of
Normandy in 1944 around 30,000 friend of
were killed why was that because the
Allies depended very heavily on the use
of of bombers and
artillery um and they didn't have the
precise techn the technology that
allowed them to to Target precisely um
they didn't want to kill civilians but
they couldn't avoid it the alternative
was to to expose troops on the ground to
Greater
risks um the problem was that as early
as 1943 the British were running out of
men
so so it was felt that that um the
priority is to defeat narcissism and we
have to take risks with civilians but
that's the moral gray area isn't it I
mean I can see why intention is very
important but isn't there also um a
point about negligence you know are you
as the Army doing all that you can to
minimize civilian casualties or are you
valuing your own soldiers lives more
than that of civilians and where does
that ratio start to become very
questionable well I mean one has to one
has to um put its to the likes of the
Israeli Defense Force in Gaza U are you
really uh being as careful with civilian
lives as you possibly can that's a fair
question to put um uh the answer has to
come in terms of the circumstances uh uh
we have there's no as it were general
rule here the question is what is what
is it you're trying to achieve
militarily what means are you using uh
could you use means that would uh expose
civilians to to fewer risks is this
military objective really important
uh but depending on the answers the
answer could be uh we can't minimize
civilians any further uh and we have to
pursue this military objective um even
at the cost of considerable civilian
casualties I think it's fair to say that
the world is watching this conflict you
know so many uh countries in the
developing world are very concerned
about this and that's why South Africa
has recently brought a genocide case
against
Israel but these but they're raising
this kind of questions aren't they we
can't just take the idea F's word for
saying that they're minimizing things
what happened on October 7th was so
deeply traumatic for them um there has
to be questions raised by impartial
people outside of Israel no absolutely
uh but in order for a criticism of um
Israel to be cogent in order to make the
case that Israel has intentionally
targeted civilians in order to make the
case that the exposure of civilians to
to harm has been disproportionate or
genocidal uh you need to have military
experts who understand military
operations you also need to have people
who know the facts on the ground um but
but granted granted military expertise
and granted knowledge of what's going on
on the ground yes questions need need to
be put to Israel as to any uh any
country that is Waging War uh but as for
genocide um uh I mean you're right uh uh
South Africa has brought a a case of
genocide against Israel in the
international Criminal Court um but I I
think it will fail because the uh 1948
genocide convention stipulates that
genocide takes place when there is an
intention to destroy a people in whole
or in part as such right so so the idea
has to be that Israel wants to
exterminate
Palestinians not that Israel is risking
Palestinian civilians in the course of
pursuing military objectives against
Hamas and if there is evidence of
genocidal intent then let's see it I
don't know there is any such evidence
and what about duty to find non-military
Solutions you know obviously Israel was
thrown into this conflict by the attack
of October 7th but can you can we really
say that Israel has exhausted all
non-military options to solve the
Palestinian problem before October 7th
and doesn't that have implications on
how just this war is no that's a really
important Point uh cind so I think
Israel is Justified um in its immediate
military reaction to October 7 Israel
has to defend its people against um um
uh indiscriminately murderous violence
um but um in the long term Israel's
military operations have to be part of a
larger strategy for
peace and I don't know what that is um
uh uh about 10 years ago there was a a
film uh released called The
Gatekeepers um um it was actually quite
riveting although it only compris
Talking Heads but the talking heads were
of grizzled Israeli Security senior
security uh um Chiefs and one after
another they said know we're in the
business of of uh preempting terroristic
violence and and stamping on fires and
we can keep on doing that till the cows
come home but what's the strategy yeah
and they said there is none this was 10
years ago and and my sense is uh Israel
doesn't have a strategy for peace other
than simply containing Hamas and Gaza
and under mining uh the Palestinian
Authority so um um whereas I think the
the the the the shortterm military
action of of Israel is Justified uh the
question of um prolonged military
operations reporting to achieve a final
permanent solution to to the problem uh
that has to be part of a larger strategy
which involves non-military means and I
think Israel needs to be needs to be
asked what what that strategy is well
the thing that reminded me of um was is
is uh president Isaac Herzog said last
year he said that there were no such
thing as innocent civilians in Gaza that
it's entirely a nation out there that is
responsible I mean that's a kind of
thing that would demonstrate that at
least the civilian militant distinction
is not drawn by Israel in the same way
that maybe International observers are
drawing it well I mean to some extent
the president is is is correct in that
particularly in the case of an
Insurgency um such as as um hamas's
recent oper ations are uh um um
precisely because insurgents hide
themselves or or mix themselves up with
civilians it's very hard to distinguish
uh nevertheless notwithstanding that um
it's still the case that Israel needs to
uh focus on uh um destroying Hamas or
disabling Hamas and not Exterminating
Palestinian people um uh so I think that
s needs to be made whatever it's very
hard to judge to what extent this
civilian or that civilian is involved
militarily with Hamas some will be some
will not be you certainly can't say that
all Palestinians are are are colluding
in hamas's um um uh Warfare well N I
think this is you know the Crux of the
issue here I mean it's such a horrific
conflict and nobody wants to see it as
destruction but this is absolutely the
Crux of the moral issue so thank you so
much for joining spectator TV thanks for
having me on
[Music]